[موسيقى]
في وقت تحتدم فيه المنافسه بين بكين
وواشنطن تسعى الاخيره للحفاظ على تفوقها
العسكري على مستوى العالم فيما تعلن الصين
عن زياده في ميزانيتها الدفاعيه لهذا
العام ورغم ان الزياده جاءت ضئيله بشكل
كبير مقارنه بميزانيه العام الماضي الا ان
البنتاجون شكك في الارقام واعتبر ان بكين
تحافظ على ميزانيه اخرى غير معلنه
لانفاقها العسكري لمناقشه اهداف هذه
الزياده في ميزانيه الدفاع الصينيه وكذلك
تداعياتها ينضم الينا من سنغافوره دكتور
ابراهام الزميل المساعد بكليه راغارتنام
للدراسات الدوليه بسنغافوره اولا دكتور
ابراهام اهلا بك معنا في عسكريتاريه برايك
ما هي ابرز الانظمه التي ستركز الصين في
الانفاق عليها في ميزانيتها الدفاعيه خلال
هذا العام
بعض الانظمه التي نتوقع من الصين التركيز
عليها في ميزانيه هذا العام تشمل الجيل
الجديد من طائرات الشبح المقاتله
وتكنولوجيا الصواريخ المتقدمه والاقمار
الاصطناعيه العسكريه واجهزه الاستشعار
وانواعا اخرى من الاسلحه المتقدمه مثل
الدبابات ومنظومات اطلاق الصواريخ وغيرها
الدكتور ابراهام البنتاجون شكك في صحه
الارقام التي اعلنت عنها بكين برايك لماذا
يشكك البنتاجون في صحه هذه الارقام وهل
تعتقد بالفعل ان لدى الصين ميزانيه دفاعيه
خفيه او غير معلنه للانفاق العسكري
هناك عده طرق للنظر الى كيفيه تحديد اي
دوله لميزانيتها الدفاعيه اعتقد انه من
غير الانصاف القول ان الصين تخفي شيئا
فعلينا ان ننظر الى اسلوب انفاق الصين
للعام الكامل وا ما نظرنا من زوايا متعدده
فسنرى ان الموازنه صحيحه وما يقصده
الامريكيون هو ان الصينيين اعلنوا عن بعض
انفاقاتهم ضمن الميزانيه الدفاع ولكن هناك
انظمه اخرى مثل المنظومات العسكريه
الفضائيه التي تقع تحت ميزانيه الفضاء لكن
اذا ما اخذنا هذه الميزانيه بنظر الاعتبار
وجمعناها الى ميزانيه الدفاع فسيكون الرقم
اكبر بكثير فعلينا ان ننظر الى هيكليه
الميزانيه وجمع الارقام للحصول على صوره
اكثر وضوحا حول رغبه الصين في انفاق
اموالها دكتور جراهام التقرير الاخير
لمعهد استقاله الدولي يبحث السلام كشف عن
تراجع في صادرات الدفاع الصينيه برايك ما
هي اسباب هذا التراجع وكذلك انعكاس هذا
الامر على الصناعات الدفاعيه الصينيه وهل
هذا الامر له علاقه بمدى يعني جديه او
اهميه الصناعات الدفاعيه الصينيه ام لا
صادرات الصين من المنتجات الدفاعيه بلا شك
تتراجع لان المنتجات الصينيه العسكريه
صعبه البيع فهي ليست رائجه مقارنه بما
تعرضه شركات الدفاع الامريكيه والاوروبيه
في الاسواق فهي سهله الاستخدام ويمكن
تشغيلها مع انظمه اخرى اما المنتجات
الصينيه فهي غير مالوفه مما يصعب على ايه
دوله شراء هذه المنتجات هذا اول تحدي اما
التحدي الثاني فهو بعد شراء هذه المنتجات
فان خدمات ما بعد البيع للمنتجات الصينيه
والقدرات العسكريه مكلفه جدا على ما يبدو
لانها ليست واسعه لاستخدام ولذلك فان شراء
المعدات الصينيه العسكريه يمثل تحديا
لغالبيه الدول ما عدا تلك القريبه من
الصين جغرافيا مثل باكستان المعروف بشراء
القدرات الص العسكريه وحكومه وجيش باكستان
معتادون على استخدام هذه الانظمه وما عدا
ذلك الدول القليله التي تتعامل معها الصين
فان غالبيه دول العالم ترغب بشراء المعدات
الغربيه دكتور دراهم الصين لديها قاعده
عسكريه واحده فقط في الخارج وهي قاعده في
جيبوتي بين تمتلك الولايات المتحده على
الجانب الاخر المئات من هذه القواعد
العسكريه في الكثير من البلدان حول العالم
هل تعتقد الفتره المقبله من الممكن ان
تسعى الصين لوجود قواعد عسكريه لها في
الخارج ام لا
حسب تقييمي الصينيون على الارجح لن يبنوا
المزيد من القواعد العسكريه الاجنبيه لان
ذلك بكل بساطه لا يتوافق مع التوجه
العسكري الصيني علينا ان ندرك سبب اختيار
الحكومه الامريكيه والجيش الامريكي على
وجه الخصوص هذا العدد الكبير من القواعد
العسكريه حول العالم وهذا لاننا لجانا الى
امريكا خلال خمسه وسبعين عاما مضت كضامن
للامن العالمي او شرطي دولي لتحقيق
الاستقرار في المناطق الساخنه حول العالم
ولتحقيق السلام والازدهار وبالتالي فان
هذا العدد الكبير من القواعد العسكريه حول
العالم يعكس التزام امريكا بتوفير تلك
الضمانات الامنيه اما الصينيون فلا يسعون
للاعب دور الشرطي الدولي بل يسعون فقط
للدفاع عن سياده اراضيهم وجيش مصمم لفعل
ذلك ولهذا السبب نرى وجودا اقليميا قويا
للجيش الصيني وعلى وجه الخصوص حول السور
الفولاذيه الذي تحدثنا عنه حول بحر جنوب
الصين فهو متمركز في شمال شرقي اسيا
وينتشر الى بحر جنوب الصين فقط لديهم
قاعده في جيبوتي ولكنها في الحقيقه ليست
لها اهميه ضمن الاستراتيجيه العسكريه
الصينيه
دكتور ابراهام الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
حينما تحدث عن مساله الغواصات التي ستسلم
الى استراليا تحدث بانها ستكون غواصات
ستعمل بالطاقه النوويه لكنها لن تكون
غواصات مسلحه باسلحه نوويه اذا لماذا كل
هذا الانزعاج الصيني من مساله الغواصات
وكذلك لماذا انزعاج بكين اصلا من تحالف
اوكوس الثلاثي ما بين الولايات المتحده
واستراليا وكذلك بريطانيا
الصينيون منزعجون بل غاضبون بسبب ما جرى
مؤخرا وما وصفته في سؤالك لان التكنولوجيا
النوويه مثيره للجدل نالك احساس الان بان
الحكومه الاستراليه ستشتري او تفكر في
شراء اثنتي عشره غواصه نوويه والصينيون
قليقون لسببين اولا لان هناك خطرا من ان
نقله تكنولوجيا نوويه من دوله لاخرى وفي
هذا المثال من امريكا وبريطانيا الى
استراليا قد يكون غطاء لنقل تكنولوجيا
الاسلحه النوويه يجب ان ننظر الى
التكنولوجيا النوويه من اكثر من زاويه فهي
تشمل قوه الدفع النوويه النابعه من الطاقه
النوويه وهناك ايضا جانب اخر تستخدم فيه
المواد النوويه لصناعه القنابل النوويه
فالصين متخوفه لان نقل التكنولوجيا
النوويه من الدوله الف الى الدوله باء قد
يكون غطاء لنقل تكنولوجيا الاسلحه النوويه
بين تلك الدولهتين